This strategy has made my trading
unbelievably simple, and now I'll tell
you exactly why. I trade only NQ, only
using one time frame, and taking only
one trade per day. And the cherry on
top, it's purely mechanical. After
trading this for years and teaching it
to hundreds of traders, I can
confidently say it's changing the way
people trade and making them believe
again in trading. And if you don't
believe me, just take a look at the
comments below from people already
trading this strategy. And the beauty of
it, it's stupidly simple. And in today's
video, I'll explain this strategy in
three simple steps, give you two nuances
that most people miss, then I'll show
you the last five consecutive trades, so
you can see both the perfect setups and
also the tricky ones. And by the end of
this video, you will know exactly how to
apply it. My name is Daxton. I've been
trading for the last 9 years, and this
is the strategy I've been using to make
at least $4,000 every single winning
day. But before we start, let me show
you my last 5 months of data.
This is May, April, March, and February,
and finally January with 73% win rate.
And let me say it again, taking only one
trade per day. This is linked to my
Trade O Eight. Let me refresh quickly
the screen, so
you can see it's not another screenshot.
And now, let's go back to the chart. And
like I said at the beginning, I trade
only NQ, only using the 5-minute time
frame, and only at the New York session.
And also, I take only one trade per day.
Step one of the strategy. Before market
open and before doing anything, you need
to define your bias. And we do that
using this indicator. I will leave a
link in the description down below on
how to set it up completely for free.
These are simply high time frame EMAs at
the 5-minute chart. And trust me, if you
use only this indicator, it will make a
huge difference in your trading. So, if
the price is at least above the 1 hour
EMA, the three are pointing up, we will
be only looking for buys. If the price
is below at least the 1 hour EMA and the
three are pointing down, we will be only
looking for sells. If price keeps going
through the EMAs, they are flat like you
see here, too close to each other and
overlapping, we will not be trading at
all. This is the first step and before
we go to the second step, let me explain
something about the EMAs that many
people keeps getting it wrong. For
example, in this day, you can see
clearly that the EMAs look flat at the
moment when market open. And some people
would not take trades, but you should
keep an eye on the EMA since the
beginning of the Asian session. You can
see here that the EMAs are still
pointing up. This is the first nuance
that I want to speak about in this video
and I will give you another one at the
end, too. Just make sure to pay
attention to every single word I say
because it makes a big difference. Now,
let's go to the second step. As I said,
we can clearly see that we are bullish
this day. Now, we want to find the fair
value gap inside a pullback in the
opposite of our bias. Our bias is
bullish, we want to find a bearish
pullback, as you can see here. Let me
zoom in.
Market open with this candle. We can see
clearly that we are pulling back in the
opposite of the direction of our bias. A
fair value gap was formed right here.
This is the second step. We simply need
to draw all the fair value gaps that
were created in the pullback in the
opposite of the market direction. We can
watch for fair value gaps that were
created after market open. These are the
A+ setups, but for other days market
open with a green candle like this, we
can use fair value gaps formed before
market open. This will be always a lower
probability setup than a fair value gap
that was formed after market open, but
it works really good when we have
directional days. If I lose, for
example, a trade like this, I simply
close my charts and wait for tomorrow
for another trade because, like I said,
only one trade per day. Now, into the
next step. Step three, if we inverse the
fair value gap, we enter. That means we
have here a bearish fair value gap. The
close of the first candle is higher than
the close of the last candle. This what
a bearish fair value gap means. If price
inverse this fair value gap, that means
if price breaks this fair value gap and
close above, always wait for the
5-minute candle to be over. Don't go in
in the middle of the candle. If price
closes above the FVG,
we enter. We put our stop loss at the
most logical place when the trade is not
valid anymore, either at the inversion
fair value gap, at the previous candle,
at the swing low. That depends solely on
market conditions. I placed my stop loss
right below the FVG, under this green
EMA, and also under the inversion fair
value gap. And for the TP, you target
the previous liquidity. If it's under 2
hours, like you see here, we target the
previous one. If we have no liquidity,
we simply target 2 hours. If you can see
here, we have 2.2 hours. This is what
our TP will be. This is the whole
strategy. As I said, super simple. If
you have any questions, drop them in the
comment below. Now, let's go to the
examples. And as I said, I will give you
my last five trades with this strategy.
No cherry-picking, no picking one trade
from every week just to show you that
the strategy is profitable. I will take
five consecutive days to show you the
power of this strategy. First example.
And like I said, we zoom out. You can
clearly see that the EMAs are looking
bullish. Price opened right here at the
market open. We are above the EMAs. That
means we will be bullish for the day. If
we can zoom in right here, we can see no
clear fair value gap in this pullback in
the opposite of the market direction. We
waited. We can see clearly a bearish
fair value gap right here. I waited, did
nothing. After we broke this fair value
gap right here, I entered, placed my TP
at the previous liquidity, and my stop
loss right below the FVG, below the
1-hour EMA. This trade was on Thursday,
21st of May. Let's jump into my
TradeZella and check it out. And here it
is. 6.5k. Now, let's check the next day.
As you can see here, this is the market
open. EMAs are clearly bullish. Price is
over the EMAs. I would be only looking
for buys. Here you can see that the
opening candle inverse the small fair
value gap that we have right here. But
the problem with this FVG, it was right
at the all-time high. This is the first
criteria. The second thing is I already
told you that the FVGs were formed
before market open will always have a
lower probability. That's why I didn't
enter the trade because it has two
weaknesses. Price started to go down. In
this pullback right here, we have only
one fair value gap. We did inverse it
with this candle. I did go in, placed my
stop loss under the white EMA, the
inversion fair value gap, the fair value
gap. So, I have three layers of
protection. I targeted simply previous
liquidity. You can see here, 2.47 R's.
This trade from the Friday is 5.12 K.
Now, let's jump to the next day.
Here, on Monday, 25th of May, it was the
Memorial Day. It was a bank holiday. I
don't trade when US bank have holidays.
Let's go to the next day.
Let's zoom out. We can clearly see that
the 1-hour EMA is still bullish. We have
a problem with these two EMAs, but like
I said, the strongest EMA is still
bullish. Price is above all the EMAs,
especially the red one, which is the
strongest. That's why I was only looking
for buys that day.
Market open, right here. We formed a
bearish fair value gap between these
three candles. Then, we immediately
inverse the FVG with this big momentum
candle. I did go in, placed my stop loss
right below the FVG. And since I don't
have a previous liquidity right here at
the left, I simply targeted two R's.
This trade was from Tuesday, 26th of
May. You can see here, 4K. This is
simply a textbook setup. That's why I
keep telling you this is stupidly
simple. Now, let's jump to the next day.
Just ignore the fact this is a losing
trade. We can clearly see that the EMAs
are looking super bullish. We had a big
sell-off here before market open. We
stayed above the 1-hour EMA in red.
Then, we formed a fair value gap right
here. We broke it with this green
candle. I did go in, placed my stop loss
below this green candle, and below the
1-hour EMA, but it was a losing trade.
This is a textbook setup. Everything was
looking great. I did go in. My stop loss
was hit. End of the day. I don't go in
another time. We wait for the next day.
And let me add the second nuance that I
told you at the beginning. You can
clearly see here we have multiple FVG's
in this downtrend. And I keep getting
messages from you on Instagram, which
FVG should I take? You simply take the
first FVG that was inversed. Simply as
that. This was Wednesday, 27th of May.
You can see here minus 2K. Now, let's
jump to the next day and the most tricky
one.
And real quick, if you want me to work
with you one-on-one every single day
making sure that you master this,
working with you on bias, on entry, on
stop loss, on everything, watching your
trades every single day, correcting your
mistakes, handling psychology with you.
I only work with a small number of
people. Apply to my one-on-one
mentorship link down below. Let's go
back to the chart. Man, this is a tricky
day. You can clearly see that the EMAs
are honestly being flat. Price keeps
going through them all, but I took a
trade and made money. I will explain my
logic behind it. If we zoom out, we can
clearly see that the NASDAQ is trending
up for 6 days. That's why my bias stayed
bullish for this day. For all of you,
when you see EMAs like this, please
don't enter. I would have never sold
NASDAQ at this level, although we were
at the all-time high, but I kept
believing that it will keep pushing up
more and more. That's why you can
clearly see that we inversed this
bullish fair value gap right here with
this candle. I didn't go in. I waited
for this bearish fair value gap to be
inversed by this green candle, entered
it right here, put my stop loss at the
previous candle under the white EMA, the
blue EMA, and the green EMA, and simply
target at this previous liquidity. The
RR on this trade was 4.05. This was the
trade on the 28th of May. For all of you
that kept sending me messages on
Instagram on this should be no trade
day, you are 100% correct. Big up to
you. Maybe I had the formal entry. I'm
not the perfect trader. I will not say I
have more experience than you, or I'm
the best trader in the world. Maybe this
was a formal entry or something, or I
kept believing. I don't know. I just
wanted to be 100% transparent with you.
Make sure to subscribe, like, and leave
all your questions in the comment down
below. Also, follow me on Instagram.
Let's meet on the next one.